wir sind zurück und wir kommen und
bleiben bei unserer ausgangs frage wie
der konflikt zu lösen ist der krieg hier
zu lösen ist und ich würde hier direkt
gerne einmal ein paar ronzheimer die
frage stellen wie die aktuelle lage ist
wurde es doch einmal ab bevor wir weiter
debattieren ja ich glaube das große
problem für die ukraine ist eben im
osten wir leben da seit wochen ein
langsames aber durchaus stetiges
vorrücken russlands was auch in den
medien in den vergangenen zwei wochen
zumindest genauso beschrieben wurde das
problem der ukraine dort vor ort ist
fehlende artillerie bislang fehlende
munition und fehlende schwere waffen
wenn man jetzt von kampfpanzern ausgeht
die ukraine das sagen sie würde gerne
gegen offensive neben auch in diesen
gebieten staaten gegen die russische
armee dafür bräuchte ist aber zum
beispiel mader zum beispiel andere
panzer mit dem man vorrücken kann und
momentan ist man die ganze zeit in einem
verteidigungs modus und das problem oder
die große sorge ist eben dass russland
lugansk und donners komplett erobern
könnte und das wäre wirklich das wäre
doch nun hat er möglich und ist auf
einer der vielen aus fehlt nicht mehr
viel muss man sagen wobei es noch
einzelne städte in wiesloch jahns und
andere in dieser region gibt und die
nicht besetzt sind von der russischen
armee aber wenn das passiert dann wäre
putins ziel was den osten angeht und das
wäre das ziel wovon viele experten
ausgegangen waren vor dem krieg wenige
haben damit gerechnet dass er
tatsächlich die hauptstadt angreifen
würde aber viele waren davon ausgegangen
dass er dort das muss man den zuschauern
erklären wo seit 2014 im krieg herrscht
gebiets eroberung macht viele erhoffen
sich natürlich dass der krieg beendet
ist gibt es dennoch die möglichkeit der
verhandlungen zwischen leidigen putin
und würde diese möglichkeiten gibt es
das sagt würde messi lenski immer wieder
selbst er sagt aber ich möchte mit
wladimir putin verhandeln er sagt wir
müssen an einem tisch sitzen wladimir
putin akzeptiert ja nicht einmal
telefongespräch auch vorher hat er nie
mit seinen ski telefoniert er akzeptiert
die nicht als präsidenten er wollte ihn
ja ermorden lassen in den ersten wochen
als er kiew angegriffen hat und das
problem bei den verhandlungen weil das
ist ja auch eine mehr und eine lüge die
immer wieder erzählt wird dass die
ukraine angeblich dort abgebrochen
hätten weil der westen druck gemacht
hätte das ist vollkommener blödsinn es
ging damals um butter also es gab die
verhandlungen ist dann wohl dann ist
butscher passiert wo mehrere hundert
menschen
zivilisten ermordet hingerichtet wurden
und daraufhin hat die ukrainische
delegation zu diesem zeitpunkt die
verhandlung abgebrochen das bedeutet
nicht dass es diese fahndung nicht geben
wir das rc lens geben wir wieder gesagt
er hat gesagt am ende müssen wir
verhandeln und natürlich weiß der
ukrainische präsident dass dort
schwierige gespräche sicherlich auch
schwere kompromisse auf hinzukommen
werden und das natürlich große teile
dessen was russland jetzt besetzt hat
zumindest in der nahen zukunft nicht
mehr möglicherweise von der ukraine so
schnell befreit werden hat doch erkannt
dass seine armee viel schlechter ist als
er gedacht hat viel schlechter das ist
nicht gelungen kehrt überhaupt nur
wirkungsvoll anzugreifen geschweige denn
ein zu nehmen und in die westukraine
vorzustoßen auch nicht gelungen was
heißt dass das was er jetzt mit dieser
armee erreichen kann ist noch die
arrondierung der ost ukraine und das
war's dann ich glaube auch dass ihm der
westen das deutlich gesagt hat dann ist
schluss das kannst du noch machen da
können wir noch einen politischen deal
machen du kriegst du ost ukraine weil
die ukraine selbst die west ukraine das
lässt der westen auch nicht mehr zu dass
putin da noch mal reingeht und an seinem
ziel fest die ukraine vollständig zu
erobern das erreicht er nicht mehr das
ist auch hier am besten keine menschen
zu erklären dass dann irgendwelche
flugabwehrsysteme geliefert werden aber
keine panzer die auf der erde schießen
das thema ist vorbei das thema ist jetzt
die wand ist ja das war ja russischen
lehrern in den vergangenen wochen dass
er planen vielleicht im jahr also hier
ist anzugreifen wenn wenn man sich den
russischen staatsfernsehen auch gefühlt
nicht so deutlich sagen nicht jetzt
müssen wir mal richtig reinhauen und
jetzt musste die russische armee mal
zeigen was sie wirklich kann die diese
schmach dass wir am besten dauernden wir
diskutieren die können nichts das lastet
sehr stark aber das ist auch schon jetzt
erkennbar da war es doch der tiger lily
allen noch einmal sagen wir reden ja
auch darüber dass ein land dann besetzt
wird
völkerrechtswidrig besetzt wird in dem
auch menschen leben die dann nicht
sozusagen im russischen wesen als
muttersprache zu neigen also wir sehen
auch über immer noch hunderttausende von
menschen gegeben die mit dem man sagen
tut uns leid anrichten beziehungs lager
mit mit william greene leben das ich
jetzt aktion der flugbewegungen aus aber
dann eben auch sehr viele russisch
orientierte das darf man nicht vergessen
dass sich der ganze und der andere
ursprung dieses verpflichtung keine dass
diejenigen team west den westen hat
denken zu hause ja sagt außerhalb der
der salafisten die miete lege meine hand
nicht da wir heuer will eine solche
lösungen hält daran ja unsere monster
sind sehr viel was können wir aus der
geschichte europas des 20
viele aber der hat ja herr jörges recht
dass da gerade im osten der ukraine
viele sind die sich zugehörig fühlen zu
russland
merkwürdig dass wie immer in dieser
militärischen logik
festbeißen uns in den diskussionen ich
finde was die ukraine braucht ist eine
perspektive und da komme ich halt zu
herrn jürgen dobert
weil folgt bestimmt wieder was wir jetzt
sozusagen wie kann hier auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland helfen um so
schnell wie möglich und so gut wie
möglich den frieden zu gewinnen weil
darum geht es nicht den krieg gewinnen
wir wollen frieden
natürlich aber das machen sie sich
jacobi ja was mache ich was
schwere waffen aber wir werden es geht
darum wie ich ihnen von anfang an gesagt
habe kriege werden durch verhandlungen
beendet nicht
führen auch wenn herr ronzheimer meint
dass guardian washington post und so
weiter alle blödsinn schreiben oder
durchgesehen thate die zitate sind ja
alle da die berichte dass natürlich
boris johnson torpediert hat auch er hat
den verhandlungsfrieden torpediert und
aus den usa gab es heute zählen sie
wieder diese bevor
über einen schon klar wo das
geschriebene vor wir erst einmal die
zurück dorthin kommen und ich glaube 1
meine vermutung ist dass man zu dem
zeitpunkt eigentlich gedacht hat man
könnte weil die vorherrschende meinung
war das ist so schlecht aufgestellt das
russische militär die kriegen keinen
stich hier und deshalb können wir die
eigentlich besiegen dafür auch
angefangen von siegfried zu sprechen und
ich denke das ist sozusagen man gedacht
hat wir wollen jetzt keinen
verhandlungsfrieden man wollte ja auch
nicht vorschnell also hier zum beispiel
united kingdom großbritannien hat gesagt
wir wollen keine vorschnellen frieden
haben und deshalb glaube ich dass es das
gibt es nicht das tor steht in der
ukrainischen da wo boris johnson da in
kiew war mit senesie gesprochen hat
na ja es wurde ja die sind zitat nicht
widersprochen haben wir haben wir haben
wir haben kein grab finden die die
ukraine muss in die lage versetzt werden
haben wir auch kein diktat frieden durch
aber ich will ihnen nur sagen russland
wird auch kein diktat frieden
akzeptieren da sind mit russland und
haslam solaris und was machen wir als
auch ein bildreporter wie sagt schuster
regina seines mega diktat frieden für
ukraine noch diktat friebe russland ein
arbeiter mit fragen ein schaffen wir den
henkel immer wenn ich noch höhere wir
leben hier über die deutsche politik
vielleicht auch noch über die
französische oder die westeuropäischen
müssen und was herrn präsident weiß ich
nicht aber ich weiß dass wir der ukraine
keiner in drei monaten krieg keine
einzige schwere waffe geliefert haben
weil wir uns nicht wollten das
kanzleramt wollte es nicht die beiden
koalitionspartner muss ich leider sagen
gucken zu frau strack zimmermann wird
jetzt aufsässig
gottlob man also und den grünen und die
grüne haben ist es noch viel aufsässig
habe er sie sehen die sache sowieso ganz
anders und es ist doch gar nicht wahr
dass es keine schweren waffen gibt sie
nicht sofort geliefert werden könnten
natürlich könnten sofort marder panzer
in großer zahl geliefert werden die zur
verteidigung der ost ukraine eingesetzt
werden jetzt wo es notwendig ist und
nicht flugabwehrsysteme die im herbst
geliefert werden das klingt vielleicht
längst zu ende wie geben wir eben er den
vorwurf hier auch an herrn kubicki
weiter dass auch fdp einfach zuschaut
und man sofort nein nein nein der hat ja
aufgehört zuzuschauen aber bis hin zur
ultimativen journalist sowie
journalisten dieses mal ausleihen mengen
sagen wir stecken ja 60 meter in die
ukraine der nächste krieg ihre partei
kann ich ja immer alles in ordnung wir
sagen diese die sagt nur wir könnten war
da liefern nein sie sagt die russin ist
sollten dann können und wir müssen nach
dem beschluss des deutschen bundestages
müssen wir uns eigentlich tun ich bin
wie gesagt habe da ja und da gibt es
eine beschlusslage die an die die
regierung auch gebunden ist aber was so
aus allem zu sagen wir schicken jetzt
auch leopard dahin möglicher parteien
die ukrainischen soldaten auch fahren
ist genauso also werden panzer fahren
kann leopard 2 können sie nicht bedienen
weil er so viel elektronik dahin hat der
muss geschult werden ja wir schicken
lieber schrott parat meister sowie zeit
dahin über ringtausch geschäfte die dann
wieder zwei drei monate dauern das ist
doch ein skandal also erstens bin ich
immer dafür dass wir die ihnen die
unmittelbar italien sind darüber
entscheiden das sind was sie wollen und
was sie brauchen und da wir uns
entschieden haben ihnen das zu liefern
was sie brauchen bis auf flugzeuge
unsere fliegen ja auch nicht rum wir
müssen ja auch welche panamericana
bestellen und bis auf systeme die
russische territorium erreichen können
sollten wir das was möglich ist
tatsächlich auch tun und wir sollten
nicht über die ukraine hinweg
entscheiden was ist weckt an die russen
ja das will ich sowieso nicht aber die
ukraine hätte auch gerne marder panzern
hat sechs mal gesagt und keine werden
geliefert ja die können wir jetzt
hinstellen doch manchmal autoindustrie
bestanden wenn wir keine munition der
firmen nutzen die marder panzer auf
platz drei aber waren wir nicht im jahr
machen dort um 1,3 millionen schuss
munition gibt es
wir müssen im moment nicht schießen wir
sagen die ganze ukraine will was wir für
die ukraine wollen was natürlich auch
wichtig ist aber die deutsche politik
und die die minister deutschland wir
haben ja auch genau was deutschland will
und sie wollen ja auch schaden vom
deutschen volk abhalten kann es deswegen
ich auch sein dass die entscheidung von
olaf scholz nicht direkt zu handeln auch
etwas mit seiner besorgnis um
deutschland zu tun hat dass ich
wiederhole noch mal wild aber jetzt
nicht ausführen dass ich glaube es gibt
eine verborgene agenda aber die
öffentlich nicht geredet wird weil mir
die öffentlich gar nicht darstellen kann
das traut sich eben keiner zu sagen
entscheide der ukraine ist verloren so
und olaf scholz hat ein schwacher
kanzler eigentlich die zeit über olaf
scholz schon hinweggegangen es ist die
ventile als ein jahr im amt moment wenn
die ukraine frage die zentrale frage
dieser zeit ist dann ist der
sozialdemokratische kanzler olaf scholz
überholt denn er ist ihr nicht gewachsen
also wir haben von einer zeitenwende
gehört die hat er selber nicht vollzogen
die deutsche diese koalition hat sie
nicht vollzogen und dann muss man
darüber nachdenken probleme suchen sich
die iren ihnen gemäßen regierungen dann
ist es zeit über ein regierungswechsel
nachzudenken und den über darüber denken
die wahrscheinlich sowieso laufen nach
frau stark zimmermann und ein paar grüne
dann ist es zeit irgendwann den stöpsel
zu ziehen und dann muss herr scholz eben
in die opposition gehen guten haben
journalisten wir drei tage das schreiben
hält das für eine völlig falsche
herangehensweise wenn wir zu einer
lösung kommen wollen und you drop
bestehen dass wir an möglichen frieden
garantieren dann müssen wir dann auch
garantieren dass wird wenn er wieder
gebrochen wird militärisch eingreifen
denn dann sind dann werden dann werden
welche waren feil wenn man wenn man die
ukraine garantiert das ist ja eine der
vorstellungen die ukraine wird um die
ost ukraine beraubt das geht in
russischem besitz über und die dann
verbleibenden keine gegen die eu und
wird garantiert in ihrem bestand aber
dann doch niemand
dann müssen die garantie möchte auch
militärisch dafür garantiert nicht
passieren
es gibt noch etwas nicht passieren soll
also bevor wir zu dieser garantie macht
kommen oder der garantieerklärung
brauchen wir erstmal den frieden und das
zweite ist wie schaffen wir diesen
frieden und ein backup sie auch sogar
vorschläge vom ukrainischen präsidenten
selbst nämlich über die neutralität der
ukraine zu sprechen über den dom was zu
sprechen eigentlich nach -2 sozusagen
über eine autonomie der dom bass
regionen das wäre sozusagen
vorteilhafter als das was im moment
status quo ist und über die krim und ich
finde darüber sollte man doch reden man
sollte diese möglichkeiten doch eröffnen
das problem ist doch wir wer was macht
die deutsche politik da der jörges recht
was macht die deutsche politik die
deutsche politik sollte versuchen
zusammen mit makro am besten eine
diplomatische offensive zu starten ist
es ja auch gut wenn man miteinander aber
man muss auch gucken dass man beide
seiten irgendwie was haben deutlich
sofort an franz liszt
vorformuliert man muss den kopf
schließlich vorformen was passiert im
moment nicht doch das stimme
denn wenn olaf scholz und emanuel marken
gemeinsam mit putin telefonieren dann
reden die nicht nur um die um die weizen
versorgung nordafrika seien geht es um
viel mehr
und natürlich es aber noch nicht
jetzt wollen wir das feld nicht eröffnen
dann geht es darum hoffe nicht wenn die
zutritt miteinander reden geht es um
substanzielle fragen dann geht es genau
um die frage wann ist der punkt erreicht
wo ein waffenstillstand verkündet werden
muss und verkünden müssen in die russen
die ukrainer können den nicht anbieten
das muss putin tun und deshalb reden die
auch finale noch einmal ist jetzt ja es
gibt mich logisch in anbieten um die
balance daran halten die machen doch sie
haben offensive bringen wenn du so aber
ist das dach sondern auch kein held das
ist mir zu glauben dann kannst du alles
aufgeben alles aufgeben also wie wir es
bräuchten bräuchten wir verhindern dass
hier wirklich der der 50 jahren ist ein
spannungsfeld zu tun gehört wird wenn
wir die russen vertrauen sollen brauchen
wir vertrauensbildende maßnahmen bestehe
nicht darin nicht dass das die ukraine
gespräche anbieten müsse sagen die
machen wir nicht das gerade
vertrauensbildend einer großen die
russen müssten ihrerseits erklären wir
stoppen wir jetzt alle kampfhandlungen
weil wir vernünftigerweise zurück auf
die linie von gehen zurück auf die
24-jährige konflikt muss ich ja den
andachten obwohl ihr fach eingefahren
waren eben ich diktiere die bedingungen
dann wird werden wir nicht vorankommen
herr kubicki ich hoffe dass sie noch ein
anderer
meint ganz im gegenteil deshalb habe ich
ja auch die völkerrechtswidrige
anerkennung von kosovo was sie ja
mitgemacht haben ihre partei auch nicht
gut gefunden weil ich sage völkerrecht
muss für alle gelten nicht nur für eine
seite wir sind uns ja alle an diesem
tisch ja eigentlich dass dies ein
angriffskrieg ist beachtenswert ist und
zu verurteilen ist ja aber das problem
ist es ist ein krieg und wie können wir
diesen krieg stoppen darum geht es doch
es geht auch darum was ich mir wünsche
dir was habe sondern die realität so wie
sie
mit denen
ist
also dann aber die un-charta mit dem
gewaltverbot nicht respektiert aber war
es die die schlussfolgerung kann alles
sein das ist nie surprise wenn sie mal
ernst nehmen würden ihren job würden sie
wissen dass wir immer für das
java seien dort mögen dass wir immer für
ein völker für das völkerrecht sind
immer
gegen den krieg im irak und
sind und immer noch verharmlosen was wo
sondern und die meisten
glauben an das thema anschneiden wir
leben in dem dilemma dass wir versuchen
müssen einen ein abkommen mit russland
zu schließen also die ukraine muss das
tun aber das muss ohne den westen nehmen
müssen wo alle miteinander lernen sich
auf ein abkommen
einigen im selben moment wo der winzling
mit den russen ja das haben wollten die
beiden nicht so richtig weil das auf ihn
zukommt ist jedenfalls verbrennt sobald
des geschlossenes wissen die ja nie
wissen wir auch dass dieses abkommen
höchst gefährdet ist und möglicherweise
gar nicht hält unter geschichtlichen
gesichtspunkten also wenn sich russland
einen teil der austria oder die gesamte
ausdruck reine plus die krim plus den
land gürtel nach russland unter den
nagel reißt würde sind doch keine immer
große kräfte in der politik geben die
sagen es müssen uns zurückholen das
heißt und möglicherweise wiederholt in
den bögen
möglicherweise gibt es in russland
kräfte die sagen damit dürfen uns nicht
zufriedengeben wir müssen die faschisten
aus gier vertreiben das heißt du hast
ständig wir deutsche europäer haben es
wahrscheinlich möglicherweise auf 100
jahre mit dem mit den spätfolgen dieses
konflikts zu tun und dennoch bewahrt uns
das nicht davor jetzt frieden
herzustellen weil menschen sterben das
ist unsere aufgabe so und wie jetzt noch
mal die frage jetzt wie soll der
hergestellt werden indem wir jetzt sagen
wir beschließen die habe wir sagen
ukraine wir sagen gar nix ich glaube das
gibt einen plan im kanzleramt und in
paris aber entscheidend sind
entscheidend sind die ukrainer die
müssen sich auf einen plan mit den
russen verständigen nach meinem
verständnis rückt der zeitpunkt näher wo
man drüber reden kann wo nämlich die
beide armeen sich erschöpft haben die
russen die ukraine die die ost ukraine
geholt haben und dann ist sind ja aber
erst mal fertig und die die ukraine
wiederum kann das auch nicht mehr mit
voller wucht verteidigen sie brauchen
westlicher waffen deshalb bin ich sehr
dafür die zu liefern aber das dient nur
dazu zu verhindern dass die russen
weiter nach westen geht und dann ist der
punkt gekommen wo die beiden mit einer
reden müssen und natürlich gibt es von
den westlichen staaten einflussversuche
auf die ukraine sollen die das machen
sollen die was abgeben oder nicht
abgeben das weiß ich nicht wieder
argumentiert wird wie sieht das
washington wie sieht das berlin das
wären wir dann erleben sie spannende
frage ist wie sie das wieder ist der
große klaus graf wollte erst als jetzt
nur sagen die jacken mit diesen stoffen
und verlegen was sie verschaffen das
leben um ihre reserven aufzufüllen wenn
mitte juni wieder aufzufüllen
mittlerweile ausgehen den raketen wieder
werden nach zu produzieren und dann
werden die nicht dastehen und sagen
reicht jetzt